hallo meine Lieben heute gibt es ein
Rocher Dessert richtig süß und richtig
richtig hübsch vor allem ist es auch
sehr schnell und einfach gezaubert ich
habe mir gedacht was passt jetzt perfekt
zu den Feiertagen oder auch jetzt zu
Silvester da trifft man sich ja meistens
mit Freunde und Familie ich hoffe ja
immer noch dass ich dieses Jahr in
Silvester weg bin ich habe noch nichts
gebucht aber wenn ihr das nicht
verpassen möchtet oder uns da Folgen
möchtet dann macht das gerne auf
Instagram weil dann nehme ich euch auch
täglich so ein bisschen durch den Alltag
mit aber ohne viel zu quatschen würde
ich jetzt einfach mal behaupten wir
legen mit dem Rezept los und die Zutaten
zu allen meinen Rezepten also auch zu
diesem hier findet ihr wie immer hier
unten in der Infobox also einfach unter
dem Titel die Leiste aufklappen dann
könnt ihr das ganze screenshotten
einkaufen gehen und Nachmachen so jetzt
machen wir erstmal die crunchy Geschicht
und dafür brauchen wir Kekse ich habe
jetzt hier kakaokekse gefunden ihr könnt
aber auch ganz normale Butterkekse
nehmen und dann selber noch Kakao
hinzufügen das Schredder ich jetzt
einmal klein und gebt dann später noch
haselnus Krokant mit dazu falls ihr kein
Haselnusskrokant habt es gibt ir für
alles alternative dann könnt ihr auch
auch einfach gehackte haselnus Kerne
nehmen schmeckt auch super
lecker so ich habe dann zum Schluss noch
zerlassene Butter mit dazu gegeben und
das hat jetzt so eine richtig schöne
klitschige Konsistenz das wird dann
gleich auf den Boden unserer dessertform
gegeben und flach angedrückt dann hat
man so ein richtig leckeren Crunch beim
Essen so und jetzt machen wir aber die
Creme es gibt jetzt erstmal eine
Basiscreme die wird später noch
verfeinert und zwar gebe ich dafür
einmal Mascarpone in meine Schüssel dann
Schlags
und ein bisschen Zucker und das ganze
wird dann erstmal langsam miteinander
verrührt damit es sich so ein bisschen
verbindet und dann könnt ihr vorsichtig
mit der Stufe immer höher gehen und ihr
merkt dann irgendwann dass es so eine
richtig schöne feste Creme wird und dann
werden wir erstmal zur
Weiterverarbeitung gehen weil das ist
wie gesagt erst die Basiscreme die wird
gleich noch viel geiler
versprochen wenn ihr merkt dass sich das
Mixer Muster in der sahn Mascarpone so
ein bisschen abzeichnet dann könnt ihr
aufhören ich habe jetzt kein Sahnefest
dazu gegeben einfach weil ich das bei
Schicht unnötig finde es soll ja auch
schön cremig bleiben und da gebe ich
jetzt die Hälfte einmal in die nächste
Schüssel so und jetzt verfeinern wir das
ganze natürlich noch und zwar habe ich
jetzt hier einmal Kikis cream white und
Kikis cream Nuss nouart das sind ja
unsere zwei Neuheiten bzw danach kam
noch salted Caramel also irgendwie kam
jetzt zum Ende des Jahres noch mal ganz
schön viel Neues ich liebe das ismr das
muss ich jetzt einmal noch in einem
Rezept einbinden weil ihr euch das zum
einen auch gewünscht habt und zum
anderen mache ich das ja auch so also
bei wenn ich z. Besuch bekomme dann
mache ich ganz oft schichtdesserts wo
dann die Creme zum Einsatz kommt und
dann sage ich immer zu meinem Besuch ja
ich habe wieder mit der Creme was
gemacht und die freuen sich dann immer
total so und das gebe ich jetzt einmal
mit dazu also hier haben wir weiße
Schokolade als Geschmack und dann mache
ich in die andere Creme noch nussnugart
und dann haben wir auch noch farblich
also nicht nur geschmacklich sondern
auch farblich zwei komplett
unterschiedliche Schichten mit
[Musik]
dabei so nachdem ich alles kurz
miteinander vermixt habe habe ich die
Cremes auch schon in einen Spritzbeutel
gegeben dann kann ich es einfach besser
dosieren und da werde ich gleich einfach
nur die Spitze abschneiden und die
Cremes ist sehr sehr cremig es wird dann
auch wenn ihr das ein paar Stunden kühlt
wird es noch mal ein bisschen fester
aber es bleibt halt richtig cremig was
ich total Feier ihr könnt das ganze auch
am Vortag vorbereiten wenn ihr das jetzt
z.B für Silvester oder irgendeine andere
Feierlichkeit macht gerne auch am Vortag
schon machen dann habt ihr nämlich am
Tag wenn ihr Gäste empfangt oder auch
irgendwo hingeht keinen Stress mehr sag
jetzt gar nicht viel zu meinen creams
denn ihr habt sie ja also ganz viele von
euch haben sie schon zu Hause und ich
bende euch einfach mal eure Meinungen
jetzt einmal
[Musik]
ein
aber natürlich sind auch diese creams
wie alle meine creams komplett ohne
Palmöl und ohne Gentechnik und ohne
Zutaten die ihr nicht aussprechen könnt
so und ich fange jetzt an mit dem
Keksboden nehmen wir dafür einfach das
mal einen Löffel ich habe übrigens hier
einmal so kleine Dessertschalen die
verlinke ich euch auch gerne die sind
nämlich auch aus meinem Shop und die
sind auch wieder verwertbar also nicht
wegschmeißen ich habe das damals als ich
mich also als Sams und ich uns verlobt
haben habe ich ja die Desserts selber
gemacht und das waren auch eins Z ein
diese Schalen und ich habe die bis heute
noch weil ich die immer wieder
ausgespült habe ich habe die sogar ihr
könnt die sogar in die Spülmaschine tun
das wissen auch die wenigsten und dann
mache ich aber noch drei so größere
Dessert Gläser also es ist so eine
mittlere Größe und letzt endlich könnt
ihr das Entscheiden ne ob ihr da große
oder kleine nehmt ob ihr viel Besuch
empfangt oder ob es ein Buffet wird und
danach schichtet ihr einfach nur die
beiden Cremes und schließt dann mit
Rocher
[Musik]
ab
ja ich Zauber mir den hamser herbei für
den Tast Test Partys Stimmung
partystimmungar nicht okay wir machen
jetzt den T grß warum gön doch den
großen kein mag gegessen und wenn ich
jetzt noch Süßes esse ich muss her Essen
ich bin gar nicht so ich Kön den ganzen
Tag süß essen so das BR das bra jetzt
nicht se ich ganz ehrlich P zur Seite
geht hier ob es schmeckt so lecker mal
gucken ob du rausfindest was ich
reingemacht habe gut pro 100 pro
undsnceme die schmeckt man so intensiv
raus ist unfassbar und hast du weiß
reingepackt unten ist weiße Creme finde
ich schmeckt man auch raus also man
schmeckt beides erst kommt die
nouurcreme auf der Zunge und im Abgang
kommt die weiße und wenn ihr euch dann
noch was vom
dieser Crunch CIA also ich alles drei
man braucht gar nicht immer so eine
aufwendige Torte machen zu so annessen
ich finde das ging so schnell ganz
ehrlich keine 10 Minuten
del ich fin das voll del Bcher oh groß
ja gönn dir boah lecker richtig lecker
Leute macht das unbedingt nach probiert
das auch gerne auch mit unseren Cremes
ich meine ich weiß ich sag auch immer es
gibt Alternativen ihr könnt die Creme
nehmen die ihr am liebsten mögt aber ich
kann euch garantieren mit unserer
schmeckt es einfach so gut es schmeckt
so lecker kann ich euch gar nicht
beschreiben es ist unfassbar gut
wirklich weessen weggeatmet das auf so
Buffet sehr beeindruckend g ich finde
auch die Cremes die wir jetzt anbieten
dieeten nicht auch nur zum Brot
Aufstrich oder sonst was da sondern S
auch zum Backen Gee und desen hat immer
die Rezeptur immer so angepasst dass es
für beides geht ja auf jeden Fall es ist
nicht zu fest guck mal jetzt gerade auch
ich habe die gar nicht irgendwie erwärmt
oder so ich habe sie direkt in die Creme
gepackt und es hat sich komplett
miteinander verbunden und das ist so
stressfrei einfach reintun also bevor
Leute sagen hier hey ich muss das Rezept
machen und ich brauche eure Creme
braucht ihr nicht braucht i wirklich
nicht alsoevor dann irgendwie sagen ja
wir wollen nur Cremes verkaufen nein
aber wenn ihr so lecker haben wollt dann
braucht ihr die auf jeden Fall auf jeden
Fall vertraut mal auf meine Worte komm
und ach so genau eine Sache noch die ich
euch auf jeden Fall noch sagen wollte es
sagen auch viele immer ja du machst dann
ab und und zu mal Rezepte wo deine
Cremes mit drin sind und ich habe die
aber nicht aber dann müsst ihr euch
vorstellen auf der anderen Seite gibt es
tausende die mir Nachrichten schreiben
Kiki ich habe jetzt die Creme zu Hause
ich habe die Creme zu Hause kannst du
mir mal ein Rezept dazu geben ohne Witz
ne wenn du jetzt ein Rezept machst wo du
Nutella hast das sag keiner was da sagt
wirklich keiner was daher nimmt gerne
was ihr möchtet aber probiert unsere
creams so Werbung Ende ich fin aber cool
dass ich gerade ganze kein Mikrofon habe
danke danke für egal ich red so laut bin
hallo bin auch nicht gem ich war ich
muss EAG war so hyped auf auf das zu
probieren dass ich auch nicht für
michegal ja wir wünschen euch jetzt noch
ein ja ein schönes se h ist das letzte
Video in diesem Jahr un gar nicht mehr
ne also wir hören für dieses Jahr auf
mit
youtubeor also wir wünschen euch alles
alles Liebe danke dass ihr uns bis hier
hin begleitet habt in diesem Jahr und
schaltet im nächsten Jahr auch wieder
ein und schreib auch gerne was euer
Highlight dieses Jahr war oh ja das
würde mich auch interessieren mich echt
interessieren geil ich muss ein bisschen
so Review
passeniew also Leute Jasmin kann nicht
mehr boror Arm abfällt bis zum nächsten
Mal tschüss
[Musik]
C